porque quiero hacerte un par de preguntas.
Creo que muchos aquí y en general en los países occidentales,
estarán de acuerdo con tu afirmación sobre el análisis de
que los sistemas democráticos se están volviendo disfuncionales,
pero al mismo tiempo, muchos encontrarán
inquietante pensar que hay una autoridad no
elegida que, sin ningún tipo de supervisión o consulta,
decide lo que es el interés nacional.
¿Cuál es el mecanismo en el modelo chino
que permite a las personas decir, en realidad,
el interés nacional como Uds. lo definieron está mal?
EXL: Sabes, Frank Fukuyama, el politólogo,
llamaba al sistema chino "autoritarismo sensible".
No es exactamente cierto, pero está cerca.
Conozco a la compañía más grande de encuestas de opinión pública
en China, ¿de acuerdo?
¿Sabes quién es su cliente más grande?
El gobierno chino.
Desde el gobierno central,
el gobierno de la ciudad, el gobierno provincial,
hasta la mayoría de los distritos locales.
Llevan a cabo encuestas todo el tiempo.
¿Estás contento con la recolección de basura?
¿Estás contento con la dirección general del país?
Así que, en China, hay otro tipo de mecanismo
para ser sensible a las demandas y el pensamiento de la gente.
Mi punto es, creo que deberíamos despegarnos
del pensamiento de que hay solo un sistema político,
elecciones, elecciones, elecciones...
que puede que sea sensible.
No sé, en realidad, las elecciones producen
gobiernos sensibles en el mundo ya.
(Aplausos)
BG: Muchos parecen estar de acuerdo.
Una de las características de un sistema democrático
es un espacio para la sociedad civil para expresarse.
Y has mostrado las cifras sobre el apoyo
que el gobierno y las autoridades tienen en China.
Pero luego solo mencionaste otros elementos
como, ya sabes, grandes retos y hay, por supuesto,
un montón de otros datos que van en una dirección diferente:
decenas de miles de disturbios y protestas
y protestas por el medio ambiente, etc.
Así que parece que sugieren que el modelo chino
no tiene un espacio fuera del partido
para que la sociedad civil pueda expresarse.
EXL: Hay una sociedad civil vibrante en China,
sea el ambiente o lo que quieras.
Pero es diferente. No puedes reconocerlo.
Porque, en las definiciones occidentales, una llamada sociedad civil
tiene que estar separada o incluso en oposición
al sistema político,
sin embargo, ese concepto es ajeno para la cultura china.
Durante miles de años, ha existido una sociedad civil,
que aún es consistente y coherente
y forma parte de un orden político, y creo
esta una gran diferencia cultural.
BG: Eric, gracias por compartir esto con TED. EXL: Gracias.